[Music]
Shaquille O'Neal aka Chuck well anything
with Shaq's name on it has to be of
quality the carnival 30 minute tour go
biggie JCPenney for the age of beer I
got my mojo going strong oh it's the
award-winning Madea vodka with the
world's only personal programmable LED
display on the bottle now I guess you
need some 5k after watching his movies
as well as some choice words written in
lights what will my dear bottle say okay
so what do we have this time Dyess
the palate cleanser after watching
Kazaam justice register what's up with
this guy it's like he's so ashamed to be
advertising this product as body is
rejecting the idea justice the villains
in this game lost they couldn't even
understand who they're going up against
sighs alright be on the lookout for a
guys
what exactly is kungfu shack style is it
throwing all the leftover copies of
steel nobody bought while building a
fort behind Etsy cans and all sport let
me check the instruction book Wow lucky
guess
this ad is every level of 90s with its
need to feel a wide angle close-ups
black wonder woman I think that was the
thing it's funny for the time period it
came out sighs yeah it's corny but it's
a lot of Genesis Super NES you miss
turkey wreck material speaking of
celebrities that were disturbingly on
everything look they're making a tea
that means they're the cereal now I
don't know just buy it look at this
girl's face that's a face that says I'm
being held hostage until you buy this
damn thing better Morse code you're way
out of this one this is also one of the
few cereal commercials that included the
PSA here I was just kidding nice mr. t
breakfast cereal presents mr. G talk
number one don't ask where talk number
two is apparently the cereal wasn't
popular enough for another commercial
which is good cuz ahead I'm teaming up
with peewee Herman talking about crack
it was weird so study hard this is do
the teachers and learn something new
every day but hell with that we want the
one where mr. T keeps his lines to a
two-word minimum
ooh yeah it is cool but after all the
songs and stunts and action going on
saying how amazing it is
do you have anything else to say about
it you really couldn't record him just
saying it's cool in a slightly different
way what do you think the story behind
this is sweet mr. cheese ooh it's cold
that's great but there's a lot more
script to read but I don't see anything
so I get paid by the syllable you think
I can see into the future living this
cartoon and she calling mr. t to twist I
know I don't have long for this shit
gets soggy like my nasty-ass cereal my
popularity is gonna expire got a store
nuts for the winner
can't you just say stay in school or
something oh you mean like stay in
school so you wanted to do commercials
for nasty cereal it tastes like crusted
rabbit shit I pity spoon stay in school
also a living the bus with a bunch of
kids it's very exciting
that's creepy people just ask more
questions look at this girl she's
swinging over John how could she do that
that's the devil's work I know this
chick cake last long
you want me to say more crazy that's all
right I think we got all that we need is
that come wrong yep you look what is
dirty cereal do part of a complete new
burger and remember on Gibson's a
scoring you got to give me a cameo in
crazy
yeah it's silly but it's mr. t silly and
that's the coolest kind of silly there
is for me I'll always have a soft spot
for mr. t cereal and is commercial too
[Music]
I'm gonna beam down to the dude oh race
you here's a bike yeah from the 80s but
it's supposed to be said in the future
it's an amazing time where people can
unpause footage mannequins have met
Frewer wearing loose black shield helmet
are all the rage and bikes are so fast
they beat people beaming down to a
planet
yeah pity we have nowhere to go ever
since the apocalypse hit do I make sand
castles again yeah for a protocol Street
machine there's not really any streets
to use it on is there but it's great
down neon hallways and giant dreidels
covered in saran wrap Oh future like a
lot of 80s sci-fi if it was weird made
no sense but was shiny
it was the most high-tech thing ever
made slowest beam ever by the way what
took that damn thing so long snotty beam
me twice last night it was wonderful
[Music]
[Applause]
weird it's pretty stupid but it's 80
sci-fi cheese stupid I can't act like I
don't get a giggle out of it
[Applause]
[Music]
now Skeletor charges into battle with
awesome artillery oh come on that's just
how Matthew McConaughey says artillery
artillery nothing except the blaster it
actually fires a light beam to stop
artillery light beam that's a fancy way
of saying we just put an awkward
flashlight on Hemans chest
[Music]
yeah that's not the first time he blogs
Skeletor remember when they both hit on
lion-o at that bar called the extending
sword you artillery bead blaster set the
first light mention weapon ever
surprisingly that's not a very big deal
they're not gonna redo the opening like
but only was a bull's-eye to the evil
eye you know outsmarting those must not
be that difficult
haha damn your palms thank you so
separately you supply the batteries the
priests and ER commercial for a priest
and ER prophet I expect more from the
Masters of the Universe the first light
mention weapon ever of the Masters of
the Universe I love the taste of your
fresh food coffee but it's not fresh
fruit its nutrient still going yep most
of us know the Energizer Bunny but do
you know where he started it was
actually a parody of a Duracell
commercial which had a bunch of pink
bunnies with batteries going out but
show Duracell lasted the longest well
energizer shit on that noise saying they
weren't even invited to this test and
not only does their battery make the
pink bunny go longer but their pink
bunny has shades oh that means he's in
cahoots with attitude attitude they keep
going and going and going and it soon
became a running joke as it brilliantly
interrupted other commercials yeah you
thought you were watching something else
but suddenly still going into an amazing
still going nothing outlasts the
energizer
yeah you never know when he was gonna
pop up and ruin a product that maybe you
wanted to buy tension headaches this bad
need a peeler this good mean extra
strength darn it all oh really that
sounds like it might be very helpful to
know going damn I don't wanted to buy
that it soothes my head from your dumb
ass drop this bunny is rude these people
are just trying to do their thing and he
keeps getting in the way of it how would
you like if you were just going along
your everyday life and suddenly
[Music]
eventually they started hiring assassins
to take them out shit
this battery business is hardcore mr.
energizer bunny hippity hoppity days are
over
they're pretty funny for a while but
suddenly Darth Vader couldn't even take
him out what the shit is this
why do the Empire even need his battery
is it like the force cuz there's a
positive and a negative side that's a
stupid he's better that seems kind of
trivial while you're at it close down
Bea Arthur's Cantina and give Han Solo
away we are the Empire
oops looking like a little bitch by
comparison now you got a skip by a guy
who came and take out a toy bunny fader
probably looks at the monkey with
symbols like will be one has taught you
well but the bunny beats him because the
Empire can't afford better batteries for
his lightsaber health care and batteries
that's always where the cuts are that's
still more dignified than when he
screamed No
[Applause]
they were funny at first but got old
kind of fast nevertheless this bunny
stayed an icon no matter how annoyingly
long it kept going mm-hmm I guess
getting your nuts often always have the
same meaning in this payday commercial a
sex hot line gets probably the strangest
caller ever and that's saying a lot
given this line of work
Mel well your credit card information
says Frank so I'll just call you Frank
something sweet like caramel huh
okay I'll go with that caramel so
different would you like to tell her
that I've done cover it with roasted
peanut mmm did you say roasted penis oh
um
am I getting punked by George Washington
Carver he was a guy who did a lot of
things with peanuts who are you you're
making me so confused concerned confused
hungry what you wanted is a payday I
guess we'll accept this as going well
what a weird-ass ad it's very clear why
this guy needs to call a sex hotline but
why the hell is he wasting his time
talking about paydays Christ imagine he
came up with another type of candy hi
who's this
um almond Joe mmm what are you thinking
about almond Joe something sweet
mmm like what something long and brown
I'll do my best with ads I just want to
put a great big nut in it yeah and I
will do my best with that depending on
how long and brown it is sometimes two
big nuts really think there's better hot
lines for you I don't mind saying that I
like a lot of fudge-packing I don't mind
saying that you're really making me
regret my job and the more coconut I can
fit inside the better
okay well I'm allergic to coconut so I'm
gonna go but bye wait wait no I'm just
talking about almond joy oh I'm so sorry
I thought this was all stuff you were
into oh no I'm actually into necrophilia
I bet you won an Almond Joy yeah I like
the quiet type a dumb man with a dumb
setup and a dumb punch line leaves only
one conclusion this is pretty dumb
making me so hungry what you wanted is a
payday hey kids everyone to cuddle up
with a toy that looks like the butthole
monster from the wall your mouth says no
but your nightmares say yes Chubbles
giggle it just about any change of life
that's giggling huh your giggle sound
like a security alarm when someone's
breaking into your house you know that
classic pleasant sound okay these things
are horrifying right I feel like only
David Lynch's kids would find these
adorable to the rest of us
they're comfortably disturbing
it's like what nel sees when she's
trying to sleep in the haunting of Hill
House it's fun to have it jiggles around
because jiggle it most any sounds if not
these things will scare you into sleep
paralysis cellos and jiggle perfect
friends renewed troubles and chicas are
also two STDs who can get if you're not
careful yeah I don't like these things
at all and the ad doesn't make them any
less menacing just get away from this
shit as quickly as possible each sold
separately from animal fair I'm pretty
sure you mean another movie don't tap
your finger at me you entitled bitch is
Star Trek 5 we got the object 5 the
final frontier
ok you two look like the people who'd be
more excited for this you do know what
Star Trek v right v Star Trek 5 they
physically go looking for God trust me
lady I know I have 5 babies at home Star
Trek 5 is perfect for them it puts them
right to sleep
Wow Shatner was such a cheap ass
director he didn't even get you a copy
stop tonight 5 the final frontier why
the hell do you have to tell your dealer
it's clearly the biggest hint in the
world according to everybody man who
would have thought we're all out of Star
Trek 5 and barbed wire they didn't do
shit at the box office but apparently
they're the voice in a generation talk
about missing the mark this commercial
had no idea how to advertise this movie
it just comes off it's unbelievably
desperate stop turn it 5 the final
frontier ya know the one where I bumped
my head we all sing
row row your boat in a row it does that
feather dance twice what am i doing take
that away from me this is definitely one
of those ads that's so bad it's good it
makes no sense but it's a pretty good
last stop today five the final frontier
so tell your dealer if you want to see
it I'm sorry I just got rid of my last
copy oh I see you've got my Kellogg's
cornflakes again it only figures the
widest of cereals would have the widest
of commercials no cornflakes are daddy
cereal son and I'm afraid you'd have to
come up with a pretty convincing
argument to get me to change my mind
problem number one a kid is trying to
steal his dad's cornflakes since friggin
one hell with those marshmallows and
chocolate I want the taste of soggy
cardboard left out in the lane second
well just watch you'd have to come up
with a pretty convincing argument to get
me to change my mind
[Applause]
well you convinced me son I am never
buying this cereal again you see dad
this is how lame our cereal is we got
these guys from mascots Pelley's toucan
sam never ran another frou-frou hand and
i got great food and oh never mind this
was a weird time I don't even follow
were these guys just waiting for someone
randomly to say they need to be
convinced that cornflakes could be eaten
by kids too was that like their lifelong
goal I don't get it man we've been
wandering this street for years and
years why are they doing this
I told you one of these days a grown-up
is gonna need convincing the cornflakes
aren't for kids and that our amazing rap
will save the day why I just don't get
why it's such a big deal ever question
conflicts again I'm tired and hungry
haven't eaten since we ate our fourth
member
I miss punky spoon get it together guys
someone's gonna be convincing one of
these basic ass no oh I see you've got
my Kellogg's cornflakes again and I'm
afraid your kids
I think we waste their lives
there's no think about it totally crazy
and dated in all the wrong ways this is
a lame way to wake up to a lame cereal
well that was pretty convincing Sun set
up joke about reviewing a nostalgic
commercial that's a real commercial here
punchline oh yeah these damn things
in the early 2000s Quiznos tried
something hauntingly different by
introducing the sponge monkeys they were
photoshopped acid dreams that looked
like villains from Wonder Pets if you
feel they look ungodly and unnatural
fear not their heavenly voices will win
you over thank you for clarifying that
you know I was looking at you saying I
recognize you from somewhere
history books I recognize you from
history books clearly I've seen you in a
picture of some sort
the Hun's it must be the Huns I've seen
you in so many history books as the Huns
but you have clarified you are not the
Huns thank you thank you for making that
clear nan Huns
[Music]
unless that's a place where pepper
served me alcohol I'm not interested we
have a home we have a tea we have to
stop it only figures a restaurant that
appeals to us don't teenagers would have
marketing buys don't teenagers this must
have been made up at the last minute
while somebody was coming off of
quaaludes so what's your ad person
getting paid thousands of dollars to
represent us sponge monkeys yeah and
they got a song goes like this which I'm
totally not just making up right now
sponge monkey I've waited all my life
for someone to say that you can even
hear the announcer being like Quiznos
has all-new subs that oh god what is
that I didn't know us attached to
garbage like that I thought this was a
respectable company oh hell no I'm out
of here
[Music]
it makes no sense and I guess that's the
point but to their credit I do remember
it and so do a lot of people it is what
it is
I just don't know what it is Wiz knows
[Music]
like any hit movie hook had action
figures to sell and they had commercials
to go along with them okay that kid is
getting way too much joy out of hook
dangling there he looks like for the
first time he's feeling shoe power power
over plastic dustin hoffman's that he
will eat upon ridicule he will taste
like victory boy they really downplayed
rufio's death didn't they honestly I
feel like a lot of these scenes could be
more faithful to the movie then for
preschoolers Playmobil hook action
figures
[Music]
playmobil hook action figures because of
a grown woman lusted after a teenage boy
all these years I guess creepy is the
new cute nevertheless it's a lot of fun
and captures most of the spirit of the
film pretty well a decent toy yet based
on a decent movie yeah can't like this
wasn't a huge thing New Kids on the
Block had so much merchandise it was
hard to keep track of but these creepy
ass stalkers will try go outside anymore
the day ball hurts my eyes gotta love it
when the new kids actually made it into
an add themselves 24 hours then I'm
brand new hotline just pick up your
phone and call someone 909 0 9 5 kid
these guys must have graduate from the
nottingham school of acting because
their acting is just being Nottingham's
look at me I'm naughty I'm nodding on
the phone girl oh that's right I'm not
we're both nodding isn't that something
I'm nodding like a dog all right I'm
serious again I'm deep but the best of
these ads are the ones that pin the
fangirls against each other to see who's
the scariest I'm number one fan because
I'm gonna pay for all their unemployment
bills when they're not popular anymore
that's not just dedication that's
practical seriously how far can these
obsessions go I'm their number one fan
because I collected samples of Johnny's
hair to add to my voodoo doll he'll go
out with me if he doesn't want a
testicles in a blender I'm their number
one fan because I've collected enough of
Danny's blood to make several clones
soon my army of Danny's will rise I'm
the number one fan cuz I have Donnie
tied up in my storage room
[Applause]
New Kids on the Block cause the kids
come with Cosette a little obsessive but
I guess that was the intent this ad did
a good job making sure everyone tried to
be their number one fan stage hanging
those kids and accessories sold
separately yeah
remember one hard our films that kids
toys how the Batman Returns get in
trouble for having happy meals and yet a
movie with countless and palings have
these at every Toys R Us what can we say
we thought the sequel would be more for
kids after seeing the first one a family
product fight evil with his mobile adult
vehicles yeah remember that from the
movie I think you're confusing though
with Arnold's other vehicle from Batman
and Robin a film that should have been
our on principle guide with the
policeman evil t1000 aim good boy his
shape-shifting is improving because that
looks nothing like Robert Patrick looks
more like Tom Arnold escaping questions
about Rose an evil t1000 aim didn't the
movie kind of address this can form
complex machines guns and explosives
have chemicals moving parts it doesn't
work that way
bullshit Kenner disagrees he can totally
do that now I think it'd have to be
seeing how stabbing weapons look like a
melting Washington Monument this time
here's another one that's kind of cool
actually pumping Arnold up with human
flesh over the endoskeleton dead flesh
compound terminator created there is one
drawback though terminator I'm
ah I don't think you're ready to fight
yet
Arnold still got close before kicking
some ass
granted you might be looking for a lot
of these looks but you know with that
package I don't think you're gonna get
much Mama's anatomically impaired as a
kendo no despite not being a ton like
the movie the commercials are still
pretty creative and captured the tone of
an r-rated gorefest seriously this is so
weird
the party's over t1000 adios amigo her
wait was it he said something is Spanish
I don't know nobody will remember it
when you're a toy company you have to
ask the question what are girls most
likely to play with dolls fashion a
wizard in a bubble that can predict the
future but usual what was that last one
ask sand or wave your hand and he speaks
ask Zander is a dating game no need to
rewind the video I'll repeat it it's a
dating game about which boy likes you
this game clearly understands every
girl's need to talk relationships with a
warlock
am I going to the prom with a geek
please say no lord knows there's no
geeks in this room that's the wizard
another question why do secret admirer
absolutely he knows everything is there
a future for me and Bobby
hello Bobbi its Melinda I think it's
time we broke up I really thought we
were going somewhere - but Xander told
me there was nothing for us Xander a
magic toy a wizard that predicts the
future could you say that again your
voice became distorted because you were
yelling so loud hello hello hello handed
he speaks guess what he predicts in the
winner gets to a special fortune granted
should I pull the plug and grandma's
life support absolutely hmm that seems a
little harsh she might pull too you will
get a phone call about this look at this
girl's face she wasn't amazed the phone
rang she's amazed she stayed in this
room so long with two nutballs listening
to plastic Gandalf it cuts before she
bolts out the room slamming the door
it's ridiculous air for a ridiculous toy
and my prediction is this will be found
at a lot of garage sales ask sand are
the talking Wizarding they're invading
what seeing how so many of you were
triggered by my joy of pokemons being
destroyed safe plays ball protect me
from reality I guess it only makes sense
to look at another pokemon commercial
this one's for a product call pokiman
ball busters what's it called pokiman
ball busters I can't believe I actually
have another opportunity to play this
but to the commercials credit I think
the item is called which isn't a ton
better apparently their popularity is so
amazing even Mickey Mouse has to China
yeah whoo wind power blows him away yeah
you know just Bob down the hall was the
one who recorded that line away even
Pikachu sounds like he's half-assing it
can they be mastered
shouldn't it be more excited and less
questioning I don't even know what I'm
doing anymore you know I used to play
Hamlet at the pokey theatres I hate
everything no there's definitely one kid
that takes this ball thing pretty
seriously
you can put Pokemon power in your pants
not your drawers these suckers are gonna
be blasting my balls all throughout math
class unless you're pokey testicles as a
fetish but if it is we know there's a
hotline they'll take them up on it I
guess it's a pretty standard ad and
there's nothing annoying about it but
it's an okay commercial just don't ask
what makes this kid squirtle cloudy
catchy
pokiman ball busters battle figures
pound bouncers and talking pokemons each
sold separately from Hasbro here's an
old-school one all the way from the 70s
mad a 70s they knew what was sexy back
then Charlie's Angels Wonder Woman long
hair tight pants for all its faults this
is a time period that knew how to be hot
so what's sizzling angle are they taking
up here there's one person nobody can
resist and that's a baby unusual start
so love made baby soft with the innocent
scent of a cuddly clean baby
I mean bad body lotion sexiest fragrance
around okay all right I'm Matt Jacob
from Twilight I don't look at a baby and
imagine them at a bangable age I just
look at them and see a baby that cool
very sexy
loves babies well scaring me right now
because
I never thought of innocence as sexy
because I never wanted to in fact it's
an innocence kind of the opposite of
sexy like the direct opposite if you
look in a dictionary or say let me just
say it say that this feels wrong your
baby wait so now my lover's a baby or
it's actually for babies both are
insanely unsettling I just want to know
what kind of creep I'm dealing with this
is every layer of you I think you can
legally show it's crazy how this starts
off so alluring and quickly turns into
super there's one person nobody can
resist and that's a baby it's hard to
even know what to say why do the most
disturbing commercials always require
babies to be in them does the agency of
creepy ass commercials just meet up and
say not creepy enough specs of babies in
there the innocent scent of a cuddly
clean baby this is eerie this is so
eerie I don't like watching it I don't
like thinking about it's just you know
who oh hell shame on all of you and the
EU you have let loose on the world your
baby look if there's anything you wanna
leave you with before I take off here
it's that commercials can be creepy
commercials can be scary
commercials can be made by very
disturbed people
he's always in so dark
[Applause]
[Music]
you
where is this car truck five video